well one of my favorites is Carl Icahn
Time magazine called him the master of
the universe on the cover of Time
magazine and I'll tell you when I first
went to meet Carl most people know of
him is a pretty intense guy I walked in
that day with my video crews you guys
have here and he says I want all these
guys to leave they said why he goes I
don't want a video crew I said they
agreed to it this morning he said I
don't care I don't want it I said okay
well I my audio team comes in he said no
audio tape I said well what am I
supposed to do here he goes bring a pen
and paper you got ten minutes and you
know I scheduled my meetings for 45
minutes and to go deep they usually go
three hours so but to his credit you
know he's had so many people attack him
that you know he needs to know what
you're really about when he saw I was
sincerely about teaching what he knows
to individual investors and really
empowering them he became very
passionate he gave me almost three hours
he endorsed the book that was been
extraordinary ever since and actually
got a friend so Carl is a teddybear aney
if he really does care but his results
are in question as I said earlier how
about a sixteen hundred percent return
if you'd invested with him through over
the last thirteen years versus seventy
five percent for the SP as I said since
a 30% compounded return if you've been
with him during that time outstripping
even warren buffett but what's
interesting about him is he really
believes that the challenge in stock and
in business is that it's an old boys
club that's his view and that what
happens is the people to get elected are
the people that most liked and the board
does what's best for the board and that
you know there's so much that isn't
really looking out for the individual
investor and so that's what made him an
activist that he's very intense and he
goes in and he buys enough stock to have
an impact and shakes their world lets
them know they're gonna be fired unless
you know they make some significant
changes and the results of what he's
produced though are incredible a lot of
people say he just got in and out so
that's why I put in the book an actual
track record you see he stays with most
these investments for a very long time
there's very few he goes in and out in
fact a Harvard Law Professor I put the
study in the book shows that over 2000
and activists interventions that have
been done the vast majority of them have
made the company much more profitable
for almost a decade afterwards not just
for a few months or a few years because
what happens is the management is what
maximizes resources and a company and
with management gets unhung Gris or
comfortable or
maybe supporting a certain strategy or
approach you're not gonna get the most
out of it just like the rest of us as
human beings and Karla's were those guys
that comes and shakes that stuff up when
he comes you know things are going the
day that I going to see him he just
recently had done a tweet a saying that
Apple was undervalued and within two
hours of that tweet Apple stock went up
17 billion with a B billion dollars in
value by one tweet and people said oh he
did that to manipulate the market he
didn't really pick the market he stayed
in he's still in he got he kept on
buying more and more of the stock even
as the price went up cuz he thought the
company's really worth it and in Apple's
case he was pushing them to try and
release a certain amount of money to
shareholders in the form of dividends I
think he asked 150 billion and and I
said well did you really think you're
gonna get that he said nah but I think
you and I pushed 150 billion maybe I get
70 80 or 90 and I think he got 90
billion if I remember the right numbers
numbers are so huge is mind-boggling
but he's still with them the day I
visited with him he'd closed out on a
stock that he'd put in I think it was 30
million and he made 2 billion in 18
months was called Netflix and he shared
with me said Tony you know I wouldn't
talk over Netflix I said do you always
you know mess with the management he
goes not if they're doing a great job
he says that's people's misunderstanding
about me I looked for great companies
you have the great colors green man as
well I'm just there to make sure they
keeping the head as well
and he said with Netflix he said he
explained to me that the chairman of
necklace of the CEO of Netflix game you
said you're sitting right where you are
right now Tony and he said the guy said
to me look Karl we've had a hundred
percent increase in the stock in six
months and he said do you really need
work to change the board right now and
Carl said I looked in and I said I have
a simple rule it's called ikons rule
anybody that makes me a billion dollars
in six months I don't punch him in the
mouth
so Carl's a character he's amazing he's
brilliant but he's out not just for
himself he's truly out for his investors
and anybody's that stayed with him was
made a fortune he's also if you're
watching this one of the only hedge fund
guys you can get access to without hedge
fund fees so take a look at that in the
book I explain how you can do that
there's no other hedge fund member I'm
aware of that you can do that without
having to pay their two-and-twenty if
you know what that means
anything he moves into you probably want
to take a look at because if you look at
the history of
where he's invested the day he invested
the day got out if you followed that
pattern he said so himself in the
interview you've had a giant return I
forget the number but it's the 20
percent range that's there but I think
also he's inspired another group of
activists he's he's looking out getting
other people to look out for investors
coca-cola one of the you know greatest
companies in our history in terms of
success anyway
has a recently gone to they were
creating out a twenty four billion
dollar campaign for the executives in
the company to basically give discounted
stock it would reduce the value of the
company by that much and Warren Buffett
is you know the largest you know
shareholder there and he had didn't say
anything and and Carl went a little
crazy and he's willing to say anything
and he wrote The Wall Street Journal he
wrote the Warren Buffett he published
and said how can you let this happen
and Warren abstain the vote said I don't
agree with it but he had stay didn't
vote against it and you know Carl was
like that's not right this is not right
for investors so I would say listening
what this guy says in that right he's
not always right but he's somebody worth
looking at because when he's looking at
a company there's likely opportunity and
it's also interesting to see some of the
people now younger people that are
starting to become investors that are
tackling some of these challenges like
coca-cola and really bringing attention
to these things so investors can be
protected and so investors can get the
returns they deserve